how was Art Basel am I pronouncing that
correct is it Bob's not even no you
don't need to go to that [ __ ] our Basel
is everything that I disliked about
Miami squeezed into one week
uh well we went because it was a friend
of ours engagement party which was
phenomenal and uh Congratulations by the
way Oren Camilla beautiful amazing party
but our Basel itself looking at art is
really fun cool thing about art is you
don't have to have taste
it's what affects you you know I mean
like if you see some picture and these
[ __ ] people don't like it but you
like it go buy that picture go buy them
painting yeah so it's you know the
reaction is going to get evoked in you
and then you can buy that piece of art
doesn't matter what they [ __ ] think
if you're buying it so that you can have
some sort of investment now you got to
care what everybody worries about but if
you just want to have it up in your room
so you can look at it because it makes
you feel a certain way that's great do
it so seeing the art was really cool but
I think what
what happened is that what I loved about
Miami was there was this great Latin
cultural influence where like people
were like having fun and they were so
[ __ ] welcoming and happy and smiling
and wanted to party wanted to have a
drink want to eat some food it was like
it felt like the holidays every single
day it's not like family there was
positivity that you often don't see and
I listen I'm a New Yorker through and
through I love it but a lot of times we
can get you know caught up in a rat race
a little bit not have that same like
outward positivity yeah but down there
it was a [ __ ] positive if you walk
slowly yelled at me exactly let's go we
got a place to be yeah so
what our Basel was was just a
combination of things that I did not
like about Miami which was like
pretentiousness the the not even pretend
it's like just like the clout chasing
the money the thing about Miami is it
didn't feel exclusive it was like
everybody coming in together let's
[ __ ] do it and this was exclusivity
yeah it was like
which I I didn't feel these things
regularly when I was in Miami or
seldomly I felt them but this week it
was like super heightened everybody
looking to see if they're about to find
a famous person everybody trying to be
in this picture at this cool party or
getting on the list of this and I was
just like yuck this is super exclusive
though right what getting into Art Basel
you have to like be invited if like
accept your invitation no no you can go
and see the exhibits I mean it's genius
it's like five people are buying these
expensive works but they'll charge 60
bucks a person to get into one of these
Museum halls in the gallery or whatever
the gallery where you know there'll be
ones for definitely for emerging artists
but that's what you're doing you're
walking around but then it's it's
there's music festivals there's DJs
there's just to walk in a hotel it's
like you know you have to show him 40
minutes for an Uber it's like to me the
party didn't feel any different than a
regular party weekend in Miami that's
the thing so it's like it's no different
than what you can access in Miami but
now the Uber's or 40 minutes and the
hotels the hotels are way more expensive
traffic is insane the traffic it's just
like it's all the worst things squeezed
into four days and apparently I was
talking to a buddy of mine uh who runs a
gallery up in Palm Beach and he was just
like the real arbosso is Monday Tuesday
where the people who actually care about
the art go and you go look at all these
works and then you go to some parties
that are like run by some art people not
a party where it's just like every
[ __ ] IG model is there yeah you're
gonna see a lot of talent but the fact
that like they're all there you know
that they don't give a [ __ ] about art
right I don't give a [ __ ] about art yeah
right but I was going oh is this a
unique cultural thing and of course our
friends are getting engaged and throwing
a party for it yeah so I'm like
you just it's like everybody is here to
be looked at instead of look at [ __ ] and
the whole part of art is you're looking
at it yeah you're even about you right
yeah yeah so I don't know I just I would
not go back no interest in going back
the Thursday party with blondish plush
the engagement party but I thought about
the Thursday race that we went to the
video of you running by is so funny
no you retweeted it it's just blonde is
spinning and then you just see Andrew
run back with just a wife beater on his
hair flapping just looking at happy I
don't know if you're on mushrooms man
people send me that video like my
personal friends were like yo come get
your boy like what is going on you were
just going crazy bro yeah you're a raver
dude I [ __ ] plur it up dude now
there's a uh yeah blondish is this [ __ ]
man she throws an absolutely amazing
party so connecting with her was dope
and um and that that was [ __ ] fun
that seems great she's fired I mean her
show the show is just incredible any
other cool link UPS uh did we
yeah
not really I did what I would say is
like you could go blonde is one of the
best DJs in the world right now go see
her at a non-basel exactly yeah like see
her and wherever she is this weekend go
see her yeah if she's in your country or
say just go see her she's great you
don't need to put yourself through that
[ __ ] battle 40 minutes for an Uber
and it says it's eight minutes away for
40 minutes yeah security and then once
you get in it you're still waiting
that's the best part you're in traffic
it's like we just love staying at the
house we hung out with the culprit guys
shout out Dylan speedy recovery broke
his foot oh yeah Dylan broke up at the
engagement party I've been I've been had
a broken
yeah yeah yeah dude it's not me me and
Dez Bryant got the same injury what can
I tell you I mean that's crazy did you
put your card in the in the Mischief ATM
no but um that guy for I'm sorry I'm
[ __ ] forgetting his name right now
but he hit me up he's like yo you gotta
come down to the ATM did you see it when
you were there no because I don't think
we were at that one and I wanted to go
but I literally didn't because I was
like do I want to wait for an Uber for
40 minutes really yeah it was it just
ruins the Bible it feels like what what
people in La go through where you're
like your friend can ask you to come
over and you have to calculate how much
traffic you'll have to go through coming
back yeah and that will stop you from
just going to your friend's house this
should be 20 minutes away but now it's
an hour and 20 minutes all my text
messages were telling people how I can't
link up with them yeah like what you who
are in your group for that weekend and
just don't even bother so Mischief who's
the brand that's behind the little nazex
uh what's it called sneakers sneakers
they do a bunch of cool [ __ ] they did
the car did you see this the key for all
where they basically have one car it's a
PT Cruiser yeah and they sold like 5 000
keys and all the keys unlock the car and
can drive the car oh that's far and the
idea is like okay we're gonna just put
the car in some random place and
everyone has an app that gets you to the
tracker that tells you where the car is
so once you buy a key you know where the
car is and you have a key that unlocks
it so people are like flying from LA to
like Boston to like go get the car to
unlock it I think it started in Brooklyn
I believe and now it's you know it
started yeah Casey like drove it right
at the beginning and now literally like
people just meet you and the rules of
the game where like if you see them you
have to trade Keys yeah or you have to
you have to trade off the car so you're
like you'll pull up someone be like hey
I have the key and they go all right you
take it it's like tag yeah literally
that's cool it's just like this
collaborative effort to be like okay how
long can the car stay alive for yeah and
so like some guy got it who's like a
mechanic and he brought it into his shop
and like cleaned it up detailed the
whole thing and so it was in like great
shape and other guys like an artist he
painted the whole thing so it's just
like this big group effort just to do
[ __ ] and so Mischief did it I think it
was dope yeah they're [ __ ] great yeah
so they basically put this ATM that
displays your account balance yeah and
uh people are going and running it up
and I was thinking what is the game with
this because I was gonna go there and
I'm like I don't want to win
you know what I mean it seems like a no
win like if my account balance is mad hi
I'm gonna get anxious because
everybody's gonna know it's not gonna be
number one but even if it's low I'm
gonna be [ __ ] embarrassed yeah
there's a complete lose-lose yeah yeah
it's like how do you find a way to
your picture is displayed the amount is
displayed I don't need all that yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
there is a fun game with it if you can
have debt that's kind of funny yeah I
was thinking like how do I be last yeah
having negative is kind of cool and I
asked and there was like a big line I
was like yo if I come by I'm not waiting
on that [ __ ] line he's like okay I
can get to the front of the line I'm
like okay what is the game that I can
play I'm not about to like move some
funds and try to win you know if you
move funds to lose though that'd be
hilarious like this is dope yeah how do
you become guaranteed last that's zero
yeah or negative negative what else
could you do ATM I mean have a funny
number 666 or some [ __ ] 69 69 yeah
something like that yeah yeah that's
kind of it that's really one yeah yeah I
don't know I thought it was a good idea
it was a great example of like uh like
not a not only marketing but also art
how do people have that much money in
their checking account that's what I
also think because nobody's paid taxes
yet this is this is nobody's paid taxes
yet so you have all your money that's in
there all right so aren't you investing
in something though in your checking
account
Bank of America app you could do it
switch from savings to checking right I
guess right
but still usually people would benefit
yeah
checking for it you know what I mean
like come on yeah for for a little clout
for a little clout so why are other
people going to our bezel are they
trying to like Network and like connect
with people and no it's the most
attractive scene if you actually yeah
there's tons of beautiful people there
every big DJ's out there I mean you guys
are there so yeah yeah we're The
Beautiful People yeah yeah but for what
we know about it like moving around the
way we did and having that freedom is
just you could get everything you want I
wonder if we would do it right to be
honest with you like I'm sure we should
have seen more art we should have
probably went to some parties on some
[ __ ] Yachts or stuff like that like I
don't think we did the best version of
our Basel speak for yourself
what are you talking about you decided
not to go and do this or that what are
you talking about yeah what do you mean
what just happened you wanted to stay at
the house and then you were oh I want to
see some art what was the day out what
are you talking about you're saying that
we would have done it right I thought we
did it right I I'm happy with what we
did but I don't think we did Art Basel
and the way that people say you need to
enjoy yeah like we didn't go to some
crazy [ __ ] late night yacht party we
didn't do any of that kind of stuff we
went to a mansion party the first thing
yeah mid we went to a Don Julio host
that mansion party was supposed to be
like the party to go to bro this thing
sucked dude some of the girls were in
Smoke shows oh yeah but it's like so
what but I'm just saying it's what is
this
version you're just saying ideas like
it's like what was the yacht party have
been like we we live and work in SoHo
New York I didn't see more hot girls in
that party in Miami this is the valley
right outside
greatest concentration of attractive
girls the same one right I think how
many did you uh did you do anything
did I not at some other things
I'm just saying listen seeing a lot of
hot girls in the same place isn't like
the most shocking so it's a
disappointing part but you did it is
what I'm saying you did it right you
just didn't like it I don't think we did
it right now yeah don't be insulted but
I don't think we did it right I think
what you didn't do right it sounds like
you did it right I think did it right
like it might just suck yeah I think you
just didn't like it
he went to a sponsored event by the not
Don Julio 1942 but like 1942's [ __ ]
Papa Bear yeah
you did these events properly you just
didn't like it it's okay yeah I didn't
like it so there you go I wouldn't go
back the opposite of Burning Man yeah
exclusive clothing it seems like the
opposite of Burning Man except the
people are coming can I tell you
something
one eighth of the amount of attractive
women that were at Burning Man like
imagine a party at Burning Man and then
just pick
just the ugliest of the women and that's
what the best party was hooking up with
this is beautiful it seems like burning
man is almost like rich people kind of
like this is gonna sound more meaner
than I mean too but like kind of
cosplaying like what like poor people go
100 and then yeah if our boss is rich
people being like let's just be [ __ ]
Rich yeah yeah let's be in mansions and
Yachts Burning Man is Montana in the
desert
yes you know how like rich people like
go to Montana because they're like I
want to be a cowboy yeah yeah like I
want to get in touch with Humanity or
whatever like that it's like that's
Burning Man is that like I want to be a
desert person I Want to Be Mad Max but
while you're in Montana you do get in
touch with nature yeah it feels good
right you're like wow it's nice to look
at these mountains it's nice to be on
the river it's nice to fish this is
really enjoyable even though you're
putting on the costume I'm getting away
from all of it it's kind of nice to get
away and the same thing I think happens
to burn it you put on the costume but
then it [ __ ] works I can't remember
what the hell it is what was that
goddamn something wager pascals Pascal's
wager you know live a God-fearing life
even if God doesn't exist because you
actually feel better doing it yeah and
then [ __ ] if you end up doing that If
Heaven's real yeah that was a good wager
you put on a good upside yeah yeah
so I'm curious if this is you getting
like more well known events like this
are less interesting because some people
go and they're like I mean it was pretty
cool but like also like Andrew Schultz
was there and this Tick Tock guy was
there and this other person I know is
there oh yeah and so for that was really
cool but like there you're a part of
their attraction you see you whenever
you want and then you go and you're like
I don't really care about the tick tock
guy I met and uh this is interesting
it's like once you remove
once you remove exclusivity the party is
the party yeah not even remove
exclusivity you are the exclusivity like
you bring the exclusive I guess what I'm
trying to say is like once you're
invited or allowed to be at a place or
people want you now you're just judging
the party as how fun the party is yeah
so I'm saying whereas before that if you
shouldn't be in a place and then you get
in you're just excited to be there
exactly if you're in the club of P Diddy
you're having an awesome time but if
your P did it you're like I'm just in a
club
it really depends on the party yeah at
that point yeah right you're so it's
like if you're P Diddy you're at this
party like oh the DJ's fire and like
that's the thing the blondish thing is
like it wasn't fun just because we were
there with her it was fun because she's
[ __ ] a great DJ yeah and she was
rocking that [ __ ] yeah right so
I I I yeah it's interesting you have a
more objective perspective on the party
and maybe that's why Burning Man is
great is because it's like [ __ ] hey
it's so much goddamn fun not for all of
us or or every one of you I don't know
if you guys felt this way on the way in
I was like ah the RV's gonna break we're
not going to get in something like you
definitely went through it you're like
I'm not going to be able to get here
it's not gonna be able to happen then
you finally do go but yeah that is an
interesting perspective yeah I want to
take that away from people who are
really excited to be in that place but
once you can go like I wonder if like um
I wonder if that's what happens with
like uh chicks or like just people not
only just checks but like people in
relationships with others because of the
clouds or because of the financial
benefit like once you have the clout and
you have the financial benefit locked in
yeah now it's really do you like that
person yeah
and if the relationship falls apart it's
like well you never really like it you
like the clout yeah yeah you like people
talking about you yeah that tells you
everything you need to know yeah it
strips away all the other [ __ ] that
would make someone interesting yeah but
it but in that moment it's hard to be
self-reflective you know you're dating
something you're getting so much clout
from it yeah you actually might think
that that is butterflies for that yeah
right right yeah I don't think people
are doing it maliciously no but they're
like oh I'm using this person that's
what you theorize about Kanye and Julia
Fox was they were getting they got
together and they were getting all this
like attention from everyone everybody's
eating it up so they were both like oh
we're getting all these great we're
getting these great feelings yeah from
the outside but we think it's probably
us two giving it to each other yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that that same that
same void is being filled yeah so it's
hard for you you can't discern if it's
external or right here yeah yeah and I
think people do that where they go to
parties they're like dude the part was
insane I met this guy and all these hot
girls were there and then whatever else
and then they're like okay if you take
away the things that you valued in that
situation with those like social
hierarch then like was it actually good
yeah the music kind of sucked and like I
was kind of drunk and that was it yeah
this house party which is like the one
on that day I don't know it was just
like I don't know boring everyone else
but I'll admit to it it was everybody's
looking to see if somebody's there like
look at you everyone else had a great
time because they're like bro this
[ __ ] comedian I love was there yeah
he's gonna be nice to be like dude his
party sucked I just kept getting stared
at it's [ __ ] annoying man and then
notice the things he likes he's like
dude I wanted to go into nature like I
wanted to be out in the woods where no
one was there like that was awesome yeah
right or just have cool conversations
with people like about art or something
that would have been kind of cool yeah
I actually didn't go expecting to want
to see art he didn't say he wanted to
see our one [ __ ] time that's actually
a lie no when you were there I believe
before him we went there for an
engagement party yeah engagement party
yeah and then when I was there I was
like I'd like to see some art this is an
art festival okay and you had the option
again on Friday and you wanted to save
the house and just [ __ ] hey so that
is um that is on me 40 minute Uber
though
40 minute Uber who's gonna do that yeah
someone who likes art
but I don't know that's an interesting
thing like I kind of understand I don't
know if this is necessarily true but
like you see like movie stars that do
this where like they'll get famous and
then like they'll have that turn where
they're like I just want to like like
Brad Pitt's like making art and [ __ ] and
I'm like like he's like painting and
like sculpting and he's like this
painting means this and I do think that
like if you're removed from like those
normal Social Circles and every single
event kind of feels like a little Bland
because people are looking at you and
you can't even experience the thing
anymore and again it's not even full
it's just the nature of like how the
hierarchy works then you're like okay
now I'm interested in like creating
something and personal connection and
like real [ __ ] that like matters it
could even just be like one Johnny Depp
you remember we stayed at a place he
used to live at in the Hollywood Hills
it was super like you could not [ __ ]
get to it we couldn't figure out how to
get out then he went and lived in France
it's just like I don't want to be you
strip away all the other [ __ ] like all
the fame and all the lights that I'm
used to now I don't like any of this I'm
just gonna go live where the [ __ ] I want
to live I don't want to be around it
that is actually I'm not saying that's
you but I am saying no I've seen that
happen with other people I I yeah I
think it it's a little bit different in
the way that I
uh have kind of
um played the game obviously I'm not
even close to a level of a guy like
Johnny Depp or whatever where they're
going to be doing like some super weird
[ __ ] but I've consistently wanted to do
the same things which is I collaborate
with my friends right like and go on
adventures with my friends like burning
man was an adventure I just wanted we
didn't make any money on burning man we
like demonetized the episode
specifically to go along with like The
Burning Man values right but
I've wanted you guys to all be there and
I've wanted us to do something fun
together and enjoy that together even
doing the Pod is like let's do something
fun together to me when we go to and
Dove [ __ ] hates this but when we go
on the road I don't want to party after
what do I want to do eat yeah yeah but
it's not about food no it's 100 I want
to just talk to you guys and I want one
of you guys to say something wild and
then we tease this person it's like the
podcast the reason this is natural for
us is because this is just kind of like
what we all enjoy to do yeah like before
this we're doing it out there and then
after it we're gonna do it out there so
for me I guess the the going to one of
those fancy cool parties before I had
any level of Fame at all
I guess was exciting for what you
mentioned earlier it's like oh my God
these people are going to be there when
you're 25 and you're in L.A and you get
to go to part of me a celebrity it's
like oh that's cool but but I never
really enjoyed the dynamic of those
parties yeah because it's not the thing
that I enjoy doing but when you get to
see yeah it makes effort a lot your
emotions are conflated where you're like
yeah did I like this or is it because
this famous person yeah I like that
there's that famous guy and uh it's
still exciting to see it last night
[ __ ] 50 Cent is on the flight coming
back yeah and it was so cool yeah I like
introduced him to my wife but I called
him my wife and Emma I called it was
weird like I was like oh hi this is my
wife like look what's that you were on
the phone I was on the phone we were
talking about it was 50 cents no that
was 50 Cent Oh you guys he said it I had
no one else heard it yes I literally go
I go I go babe uh this is an absolute
Legend and then I look at him and I go
this is my wife hey yo
and then he kind of smiled and he was
this is how much respect I ever said
descent I thought he was in a seat
behind me directly and I didn't even put
my seat back for like an hour because
that is a light I gave him an hour right
where I was like he might be crammed
that's what he said like I like it cram
50 Cent then I found out it was my
wife's seat and I was like
what's up can I get a head massage hello
so like I think there is that having
that
there is that excitement that we all
have in being around these people blah
blah blah dude like nine years ago my
friends went to 40 40 club to watch the
finals and one of them got a high five
from Jay-Z They still talk about it to
this day yeah is the [ __ ] coolest
thing that will ever happen to them yeah
and I don't think that ever goes away
when you're really excited about the
people you're meeting at but when the
people at the party are some like
[ __ ] private Equity douche yeah like
I'm like oh God I shook hands with the
guy who makes money off of people's
money
overseas for different money to make
more money wow
you're crazy like [ __ ] that I'm dropping
my seat immediately but before we take
off you can use some discomfort yeah
exactly [ __ ] you yeah get a private jet
uh anyway so yeah I think that was a
good that's a good point yeah but being
able to focus on the things that that uh
bring you Joy and I'm so [ __ ] I think
about that I'm so lucky that I get
immense Joy from hanging around with my
friends like that is the Pinnacle of Joy
yeah and uh my friends my wife even
spending time with my wife like that's a
[ __ ] awesome time so some shocking
shockingly